[Music]
if you haven't yet mastered cinema 4d
it's not too late
in fact there's never been a better time
to do so
cinema 4d is fast becoming an industry
standard program preferred by many
studios and companies so those who
master it can win big time
but a lot of designers find the
interface intimidating and simply don't
know where to begin
don't let this be the reason why you get
left behind
i'm shannon wilkerson a motion designer
with more than 10 years of experience
working in cinema 4d
in cinema 4d quick start i'll teach you
how to use the program to its full
potential with bite-sized powerful
lessons and step-by-step real world
projects
not only will you learn the ins and outs
of the program interface you'll go deep
into the principles of 3d design from
lighting modeling texturing rendering
and much more so you can use the program
like a true pro
your mind will be blown away by what
you'll be able to create in this course
and how quickly you'll be able to level
up your 3d credentials
it's time for you to move beyond 2d
designs and develop an in-demand
industry skill that will supercharge
your work and your career so don't wait
a moment longer to start learning cinema
4d the right way join thousands of
others who trust motion science as one
of the best quality motion design
education providers online sign up today
and get a lifetime access to cinema 4d
quick start i'll meet you there
you